fate
it soars on the wind
it rises from the grave
it stalks the ocean floor
you cannot hide from fate
but you can make your own
[Music]
suckers
a quick question we're not talking about
yet right that is correct it's my
favorites
hi i'm kayla bellmore and i'm senior
producer around tiny tina's wonderlands
[Music]
so what's really unique about wonderland
is it's a looter shooter which is
you know pretty classic for gearbox
software but for the first time ever
we're setting it in a brand new fantasy
environment
even though it's inspired by some of the
content we've made before with assault
on dragons keep a fan favorite
roll for initiative it's a completely
stand-alone plot new set of characters
with some nods to the past but if you've
never played a borderlands game before
you can absolutely jump right in and
enjoy it just as much
so we're absolutely excited to talk
about all of our new enemy types
uh so that is one of our wyvern enemies
you will absolutely
be fighting them they're not your
average wyvern so
of course we've got goblins you
definitely can't have a fantasy game
without goblins but again
we like to make them our own thank you
so much everybody i hope that you are as
stoked as we
are about tiny tina's wonder plans
follow us on our social channels to find
out the latest and greatest news
enjoy the rest of the show